hey guys this next clip was made
possible by news voice which is a
democratized news app created to fight
back against the filter bubbles caused
by corporate media download for free
from news voice calm slash Pakman or
click the link under this video this is
a story about two major topics that are
important to me that I talk about
frequently one is the size of the
American military and defense apparatus
and two this is a story about Democrats
and Republicans being the same on too
many issues let's start with that second
part okay I've told you at this point so
many times that Democrats and
Republicans aren't the same that voting
for a Democrat is not the same as voting
for a Republican at a sort of base
general level that on many important
issues they're extraordinarily different
net neutrality minimum-wage social
issues abortion and gay rights education
policy many of them on health care
there's this very very long list of huge
differences between your average
Democrat and your average Republican at
the federal level but as I've said
before on a ton of the basic structural
fundamental issues that guide our
politics Republicans and Democrats are
effectively the same so no matter what
their rhetoric is on campaign finance
they effectively both perpetuate the
status quo system that got them into
power in the first place although some
of them like to say I do want to change
the campaign finance system no matter
their rhetoric on spending priorities
they in the end when the rubber meets
the road mostly we'll all participate in
furthering this constant growth of
defense spending and military spending
at the expense of funding other things
the American military is more than
well-funded millions of military
personnel tens of thousands of military
aircraft thousands of Tanks dozens are
nearly two dozen I think aircraft
carriers dozens and dozens of submarines
we have endless nuclear weapons bases
all over the world
just like by a lot by a huge margin we
do the most military spending of any
country period it's not even close the
Senate recently passed a new defense
spending bill that increases the
military budget by another 17 billion
and the headline is accurate which is
Bernie Sanders was the only Democrat to
vote against this bill but there's also
more to it and you actually do have to
look into the details to really
understand what's going on here
93 senators voted YES on this bill six
suppose that fiscal conservatives in the
Republican Party voted against the bill
and Bernie one Democrat voted no on this
bill so I want to be clear there was
also health spending tied up in this
bill there was a government shutdown
riding on passing this bill so it's not
as simple as the headlines say which is
Bernie's the only Democrat to vote no on
giving more money to the military
because yeah there was spending on
health that was in there and keeping
government open but this is exactly how
Democrats end up hiding behind and
getting away with mostly doing business
as usual with Republicans on defense
spending on military spending and
keeping the entire thing going and this
is how they play the game publicly
Democrats want this and Republicans want
that vote for me because I'll do X no
vote for me because I'll fund Y but then
they get together and they combine the
X's and Y's into one bill so when the
Democrats get slammed because hey you
guys are all funding an even bigger
military I thought you didn't want to do
that they can hide behind well listen
there was important health spending in
the bill there was important education
spending in the bill I wasn't going to
vote against that and that's true
there was important health and education
spending in the bill because that's how
they arranged it they agreed to have
military and health spending in the same
bill you don't have to do that the bills
don't have to be done in this way so is
it as simple as Bernie's the only dem to
vote against everybody else is bad no
it's not but enough Democrats should get
together Pat to say we got to separate
these provisions into multiple
Bill's it's us who decides how we won't
vote on this stuff let's separate it and
kudos to Bernie Sanders for sticking to
principle here especially because
education and healthcare are big topics
of his and you know it's just
unfortunate that that defense spending
is always the third rail of politics
like you always just have to support it
it's never a question it's never a big
controversy in the media and you know I
mean very few Republicans were able to
go along with that too it's sad to see
that Bernie Sanders was the only
Democrat well but is it good for Bernie
because at the same time he did vote
against the health and spending at the
health and education spending like I get
it it passed anyway and in the end his
vote didn't make a difference but this
is how they get you because then later
they can say Bernie Sanders voted
against increasing education and health
care spending is this the man you want
represent right like so and it would
technically be true but it doesn't
really fit it doesn't tell us the spirit
of what it was that went on I think that
critique would fall flat on its face
though because Bernie's the one out
there pushing for Medicare for all in
free college so the spirit of what's
being said there wouldn't hold true to
the American public I hope that you're
right I hope that you're right and of
course they get away with it and when
you go to them and say just separate the
bills right separate this stuff they'll
say oh but we're not there yet we can't
change that yet we've got to play the
game you know until we're able to get a
majority or if they have a majority
they'll say we can't really do that
right now we got to have a bigger
majority in order to be able to separate
the bills out and this is why we need to
vote but we've got to go beyond it right
like this is going to the level of we
need we need civil disobedience we need
to be thinking way bigger if we actually
want change here